6 22 on your Thursday morning well what
an iconic group of fellas we have with
us of course it's NFR and it's been 50
years since John Wayne's famous movie
The Cowboys joining us right now are
some of the guys who were in the movie
along with the Duke went back when they
were kids also John Wayne's
granddaughter is in the house Anita
Swift hi Anita hi there nice to have you
with us so they're going to talk about
the movie and a new cocktail book
inspired by all of John Wayne's Western
so I'm going to do a roll call tell me
first of all we'll say a name and you
tell us who you played in the movie Mike
Pyatt right here who were you in the
movie I played Homer Weems that was a
cute one yeah
awful fellas Al Barker who were you in
the movie I played fats okay Robert
Carradine yeah hi I played slim okay
Nicholas movie who are you I played Dan
Four Eyes okay and Steve Benedict Austin
my year I played Steve okay and Stephen
hudis who are you hi I've played Charlie
awesome so fellas how old were you when
this movie was made 17 14. just turned
14. my goodness so 13 I turned 14 on the
set yeah 13. now so it's a classic movie
but maybe there are some people who
haven't seen the movie who wants to go
over the plot what was actually
happening in the movie what was it all
about well what happened was uh John
Wayne was getting ready to take his
cattle to Market and all his uh hands
his cattle guys they went off to try to
find gold so he was left with no cattle
hands to move the cattle and he was
stuck so he decided Well I guess I
should try school kids and he came by
the school he looked at us all and he
put us through our paces and used us to
get the cattle to Market so were you all
child actors at the time had you been in
other movies was this a first person
yeah what was it like I was cowboy
background and I was uh had a roping
Arena and we roped and uh you know
nothing around Hollywood at all and just
got cast for the movie but John Wayne
was such a superstar what was it like
being around him and being in the movie
John Wayne and I'm said this a million
times John Wayne was a tremendous Father
Figure an awesome individual if if I
didn't have the awesome dad I had I'd
love to have John Wayne as my father all
right so Anita we don't want to leave
you up because you guys are in town for
NFR and there's something going on a
cowboy Christmas first of all thanks for
being here what's happening in cowboy
Chris so we have a booth there with
Justin Boots and the cowboy Channel and
we are
um there with these guys they have an
autograph signing at word booth 2539 and
they're there every day from 12 to 3
uh assigning autographs and we are there
with some merchandise that we sell and
um we're there just uh meeting people
and having a great time and so as a
granddaughter did you have a lot of time
with my granddad I did I was 22 when he
passed away
and I had a lot of fabulous time with
him so yeah he was a wonderful
grandfather I noticed you have a chance
to get over there and grab a couple of
the goodies and while you're doing that
fellas tell us more about the experience
of being how long did it take to make
the movie or how many days were you guys
involved in the shooting four months of
hanging out with John Wayne and that
doesn't include the two and a half
months where the actors were trained to
learn how to ride a horse and look like
they knew what they were doing well some
of you guys already had a lot of
experience doing that yeah it was like
50 50. uh real cowboys and actors okay
uh so uh tell us what you got over here
we have a brand new cocktail book out
because I'm sure most of you knew that
he liked his cocktails what a shock when
he wasn't
um acting right and so we have a a
liquor line uh we we have a bourbon and
a tequila and our our new cocktail book
has um recipes uh for drinks and food
okay named after some of his movies and
some of some of the things he like to do
like throw a good punch there you go and
unfortunately we'll run out of time so
head over to Cowboy Christmas and go see
all of these guys right and
dukespirits.com awesome hey thank you
guys for being with us and